on the number line below which point
more closely represents the principal
root of 43 Oricon viewed as a positive
square root of 43 and I encourage you to
pause this video and just looking at
this try to approximate where a is and
where B is and let's think about which
of those numbers is closer to the
principal root of 43 so let's go through
each of them so point a right over there
it looks a little bit more than halfway
along the way between six point five and
six point six halfway halfway it looks
like it's right right over there so that
would be six point five five so I would
estimate a to be approximately a looks
like it's approximately six point five
six a it looks like it's approximately
six point five six so let's square that
and see what we get so six point five
six times six point five six and
obviously if you had a calculator you
could just punch the square root of 43
in but we don't want to do that or or
this exercise doesn't want us to do that
so I'm not going to use a calculator for
it so 6 times 6 is 36 6 times 5 is 30
plus 3 is 33 6 times 6 is 36 plus 3 is
39
now let's you think about this five so
let's store as ear o here 5 times 6 is
30 3 up there 5 times 5 is 25 plus 3 is
28 28 5 times 6 is 30 plus 2 is 32 and
then we've got another 6 here well we
already figured out what 6 times 6 5 6
is it's 3 9 3 6 so let's throw our 2
zeros here and we're gonna have a 6 a 3
a 9 and a 3 and now we can add
everything together and we get 6 3 C 9
Plus 8 is 17 plus 6 is 23 and let's see
2 plus 3 is 2 plus 3 is 5 another 5 you
get 10 and let's see this is 13 so you
get 4 as he and you have 1 2 3 4 numbers
behind the decimal 1 2 3 4
this gets just a forty three point zero
three three six so this is pretty close
to forty three this is pretty pretty
pretty pretty close to forty three
without even thinking about what B
squared is I'm I'm already predisposed
to saying that a is going to be closer
but let's just try let's just think
about where B is actually we don't even
have to look we don't even have to look
at B because a is pretty close and it is
already a squared is already larger let
me write this so a squared if we
approximate it right at six point five
six so let me write this down six point
five six squared six point five six
squared which is forty three point two
zero three 36 is already greater than is
already greater than forty three or
another way of saying it six point five
six is already greater than the
principal root of 43 so a looks like
it's already it's it's pretty close and
it's already if anything it's a little
bit larger than the square root of 43 so
B is going to be that much as B is
larger than a so B is going to get us
even further above if we square B we're
going to get even further above 43 so we
can rule out B and that saves us a lot
of computation and so we're going to go
with a a is a pretty good approximation
of the square root of the square root of
43